U.S and Canadian Coast Guards have
launched a search and rescue mission
after a tourist submersible lost contact
on its way down to the Titanic shipwreck
in the North Atlantic the vehicle was
taken 600 kilometers from the Canadian
province of Newfoundland to the site of
the sunken remains of the British
passenger ship which is nearly 4 000
meters beneath the surface the company
that operates the vessel says there are
five people on board and a few days of
life support Colin Baker has more on
what could have happened to the
submarine
the Titanic shipwreck is very deep
located nearly four kilometers beneath
the sea surface these are the latest
images we have of the ship which was
actually mapped by a private company
called Magellan just this year it's 600
kilometers away from the coast of Canada
and there are a few scenarios of what
might have happened to the Titan
submersible after it descended to the
wreckage and lost communication with the
surface crew in One it floats back to
the surface but it loses communication
and is reported to be sealed from the
outside so it would need to be spotted
to be rescued in another it's either
mid-ocean or on the sea floor and
finding an object that small from that
distance requires specialized tools
sonar beacons provide acoustic pings
that bounce off of hard objects
underwater but their accuracy at such
great depths is limited so multiple
sound frequencies are used remote
operated Vehicles will help but they
have to be deployed to the site and
timing is crucial the crew only has a
few days worth of air
oh Kristen steamy is live for us now in
New York and Kristen we've had an update
in the past hour from the U.S Coast
Guard what do they have to say
well this has become a multi-agency
multi-country response effort that the
Coast Guard of the United States is
coordinating but they admitted recently
that they do not have all of the
equipment or the expertise that are
needed for this and that's why they are
pulling resources from so many different
areas the U.S Coast Guard Navy now the
Air National Guard is getting involved
here in the United States the Canadian
Coast Guard as well as military uh is
also involved and also now a private
industrial vessel known as deep energy
is being used for underwater search this
is a vessel that has the capability of
searching underwater which is a rare
thing not widely available and so that's
being put to task and they're asking
other commercial vehicles also to keep
an eye out for the missing submersible
it's a very complicated search and
rescue already they've looked at over
some 7 500 uh
square kilometers out at Sea they've
been searching above the ocean as well
in planes on vessels using Sonar
anything at their disposal they are
working around the clock they say
because it is such a crucial and dire
situation the latest estimates by the
Coast Guard are that there's only about
40 hours left of oxygen on board making
this a very tricky challenging situation
the U.S Coast Guards Captain Jamie
Frederick described it just a short time
ago
on behalf of all the men and women of
the United States Coast Guard and our
search Partners we offer our most
heartfelt thoughts and prayers for the
five crew members their families and
their loved ones
our crews are working around the clock
to ensure that we are doing everything
possible to locate the Titan and the
five crew members
yesterday we stood up a unified command
consisting of expertise from the United
States Coast Guard the United States
Navy
Canadian Armed Forces and Coast Guard
and the Titans parent company Ocean Gate
Expedition
I'm Kristen after all this locating the
vessel is only half the battle isn't it
absolutely uh the Again The Vessel could
be on the bottom of the ocean it could
be near the surface if it's near the
surface it still needs the people inside
still need assistance in order to get
out because it's sealed from the outside
somebody needs to open the hatch for
them to get them out of it if it's at
the bottom of the ocean it could be
three to four kilometers down they have
to find it it's intense water pressure
down there only certain vehicles are
capable of going to that depth so they
would have to locate The Vessel and then
bring it back to the surface so a very
very complicated rescue effort but
clearly a lot of effort is being made to
locate these people and save them okay
questions leave me joining us there from
New York thanks very much Kristen